ah she's in London she's staying with
Rosamond she can't be she was here for
lunch she didn't say anything she would
up this afternoon she'll be back
tomorrow so I've asked you to come for
tea you must persuade her to leave more
Bagshaw alone
I don't believe even the mob will pick a
quarrel in front of the King I wonder if
he can come early are you excited I am a
bit are you would it be common to admit
it not to an American my government also
known as Crawley joins us at the table
I'm should we call your lady Grantham
would that be better yes and whatever
you Elizabeth
one of your colleagues said it's like
coming back for a school help from
school holidays another one said it's
like getting into a nice pair of cozy
slippers what was it like for you to do
the movie after well it was absolutely
and almost scarily as though we'd never
stopped really that thing that happens
when you get to a certain age and time
just flies so fast yeah it had been
three years since we last shot the
series but as soon as we were all in the
house again it just seemed as though
really we were back and did you the
family did you feel pressure because of
those of us who watched the show and I
certainly did it's so we have such
expectations about what this movie is
going to be did you feel the pressure of
that you said listen we're just gonna
make a delightful fun movie is how they
described it when I was very relieved
that I wasn't the one that had doraid it
there you go
you know I because I did feel a lot of
pressure I mean I was actually thinking
is this such a good idea because people
have so much affection for those who are
actors and that series and it's a risk
and I think there are lots of
incarnations of the script that were
thrown out and they experimented with
different tacks and finally decided no
we want to give the fans what they want
we want to go back in time and we
indulge in those the nostalgia of people
missing the series as much as they miss
that era and just let's hang out with
these people that we've spent so much
time with and we've invested a lot in
and let's have an adventure listening to
the music it's like
king and queen we're coming a year later
and hanger years older and the king and
queen are coming yes dinner and all the
drama that ensues you felt the same way
about the music I love the music could
be our music like going into the weather
just makes you feel dignified but one of
my questions there's nostalgia involved
in the show
I loved the PBS series and I'm looking
forward to the movie and why do you
think people connect with that era so
much what is it about it that makes us
want to swoon you know I think that
things are moving so fast at the moment
that psychologically we cannot actually
keep up with it we cannot actually deal
with the enormous amount of choice we
have our enormous ability to talk to
everyone at any time the day the the
kind of stimulation that is constantly
being fed into our brains and to go back
to a place in time where there was no
choice people had a job they accepted
the job for life people had a role they
were told and they knew how to behave if
they didn't know Carson would tell them
easier there's something to be said to
Elizabeth about destroying about
disagreeing without destroying yes we
were talking earlier about the value of
good manners yes I think that's
something that this show has reminded
people that to treat each other with
respect no matter what our walk of life
I mean the the downstairs people are
just as interesting to us to the camera
as the upstairs people it isn't
everything to be the rich guy and and
people disagree but but they respect
each other as people
you had your premiere for this the other
night at Lincoln Center coming home and
a way for you because you went to
Juilliard I did but almost as soon as
you got to Juilliard you got plucked
into your first film which was ordinary
people at the age of 19 yeah and then
your next film you get an Oscar
nomination that was crazy
what was that time like I feel as though
it was a trauma it's very strange
well it must have been shocking you
almost have a sort of blackout about it
because I think that sometimes
thing that is a outwardly successful
experience it can be a traumatic one
because it changes your life in a way
that it's hard to catch up with and
suddenly I was in a different level up a
different pay grade to all my friends
who were still in college but you know
it so it's been okay I think it's so
cool you're in a band Sadie & the
hotheads yeah are you say to her you the
hothead I'm Sadie Sadie yeah and my
musicians are just so nice and so gentle
and so sweet that I had to call them the
hothead there are many sides to
Elizabeth many sites nice to have you
here thank you Congrats on the movie
love you and hustlers there's a lot to
choose also a lot of fun and you can do
both feature yeah having me
Downton Abbey opens in theaters this
Friday